reverse engineering um is used all over
the place as you say is at a high level
it's just trying to take something that
exists and
from what you have the thing you have
trying to work out how it works
so rather than sort of having access to
the source code um or the original
specification for the program that's
written you've only got the final form
or perhaps the source code at a low
level and you're trying to work out how
it all works so that you can then
produce an alternative the classic
example of this was compact when they'd
cloned the original pc
all the hardware was open standard stuff
you could go by the chips off the shelf
from intel for the interrupt control of
the cpu and so on the key that made it a
pc though was the ibm proprietary bios
that was on a chip on the motherboard so
if compact wanted to produce a clone
they needed to give their hardware they
couldn't give it the same software
because that was copyright but they used
to give it similar software that worked
in exactly the same way so that when you
loaded dos onto it when you loaded the
software it ran in the same way so what
compact would have done
is reverse engineered the software
someone would have stacked they would
have taken the bios
off the motherboard they would have
looked at the bytes stored in that
rom chip and then they would have worked
out how that bios program ran on the
computer
and then they could then produce a
specification to create their own
another time you might use it you may
have a piece of software that
is no longer supported
or has been around for a while you need
to extract data from it classic example
of this was the bbc doomsday system this
was a phillips laser vision player which
was a laserdisc multimedia system
produced in the late 80s by the bbc
running on the bbc microcomputer system
that sort of captured the snapshot of
the uk in 1986
but
those later discs are now rotting
literally
uh and the data is inaccessible unless
you can find a working player a working
system
a working bbc micro and so on so people
have reverse engineered the software
that to try and extract the data
these days where people use reverse
engineering is in cyber security um if
you get a piece of malware
you want to know what does that malware
does who wrote it
um sort of
is is what i've seen it do the only
things it will do always at some later
stage waiting for to jump out and run at
a later point to find out what that
malware does and so again reverse
engineering is one of the tools you
would use to sort of work out what that
malware does let me think about software
for a startup
you when you code something you then
send it usually through some kind of
assembler it turns it into a yeah that's
a really good place to start if we think
about when we wanted to write a piece of
software we'll normally start off with
an idea let's say we want to write a
program to count words in a piece of
text
so we start off with that idea
and we want to count
words and then as we write that software
we start to break it down into chunks we
start to define how certain things are
going to work until eventually we get to
a point where we can write the program
code
and then once we've written the program
code we can feed that through a compiler
which will produce the machine code and
it'll encode that in a format that the
operating system can run
because it's not just usually unless
you're running something like dos or
writing the bios on the thing just raw
machine code bytes you've usually got
some data around there that tells it how
to load it in what's the program code
what's data what are the libraries it
might link to as well perform the
executable format probably should do a
video on that at some point so at the
other end we're going to end up with a
file
on our system
and let's just use the windows.exe
extension so we know what it is so we're
going to start from an idea
and we're going to end up
with the program code that we can run
so if we're going in that direction
this is programming coding
software engineering whatever
you want to call it so that's in that
direction reverse engineering
is basically going in the other
direction we've got the program we may
know what he does at some point because
we've run it might be a word processor
it might be a problem that counts words
it might be a piece of malware we're
unsure of what it does it might be the
biosphere pc we've probably got some
high level idea what it is but we wanted
to go in the other direction so reverse
engineer is going in the other direction
so we've got some idea of what the
program does but we also want to know
how it does that how it's implemented
because if you think about if we're
trying to write a program
that counts words
the cat sat on
the
mat full stop
we've got our
text there now i want to count the words
in that okay how many words are they
i've got six six what are you defining
as a word as
oh yeah so i i would say a collection of
letters that is preceded or whatever by
a space okay so if we're going to do
that so that would be one word
separated yeah separated but that that
would be two words that would be three
words
is the full stop part of the word or not
uh yeah tbc and that's the point that's
one of the things we have to define so
we're starting
from
the idea we want to count words the next
thing we have to do
is we need to start to define that so we
need to define
those ideas in
more detail and this is a simple program
so we need to define what a word is and
we could say something like
a word is a
run
of characters
that
aren't spaces okay what's the space
well that's a character of some sort in
there yeah but again we need to define
it so the space
is
ascii
32 that's the normal space we probably
want to put the tab character which is
ascii 9 line 3 carriage return so we've
got 10 13 probably some others that
probably do for now answers on a
postcard for the definition of spaces
we'll do a whole video on what space is
and it can be no no i'm only joking but
but the point i'm making is we have to
define what these things are
so as we go from the idea
we start to make it more solid we start
to break it down so we're sort of
breaking the problem down just like
we've done here we now know what a word
is
we now know what the space between these
the separations between them we have to
define that
a space is that and so we could also say
here that separate words by
one or
more
spaces
and for a word counting program
we probably don't need any more
definitions for that if we're building
something bigger let's say we're
building a word processor we would have
data structures that we need to define
how we're going to store a line of text
do we saw
a paragraph as a series of lines after
they've been formatted or was a single
block and then we say it's the end of
paragraph at the end of that
how do we define all those things we
need to define those things
so i'm going to say that we break down
the program into a series of data
structures and the other things we have
is the program
code or the other way of describing that
is the algorithms nicholas worth read a
book programs equals data structures
plus algorithms fred brooks the author
of the mythical man month made a a quote
that sort of show me your flowcharts i
your program and conceal your tables i.e
your data structures and your program
will be a mystery to me show me your
data structure show me your tables and i
want you to look at your flow charts and
paraphrasing uh because the pro will be
obvious and so we break down the idea
into the data structures the algorithms
we're going to use and then we will
express them
in a programming language and i'm going
to use c because what else is there to
use and then that high level language
here will start to express these
algorithms that start to express these
data structures as code at this point
we're probably still thinking in
abstract terms and then once we express
that in code so that's the actual coding
part of it eventually we will compile
and we will
link this
using our compiler to produce the
executable
and as we go from the idea here
we're getting
further away from just a raw idea we're
getting further away from the data
structures towards what the cpu will
understand so it's becoming more
specific is this kind of a is this a
standard pipeline does everything go
through this development pipeline or is
it pretty
i mean yeah you would probably i mean
minor coding you may design a data
structure
but that data structure is there you're
breaking it down it's not you're going
to have it's not a waterfall nothing's
ever a waterfall in computer science
unless you're doing it wrong
i'm only joking uh you've got the idea
that it'll end up being more specific
and so on when we reverse engineering
effectively what we're trying to do
is get to around this sort of stage
from only having this so it might be
that we want to work out some of the
data structures how they're using the
program like the bbc doomsday we want to
be able to process the data write a new
front end for it so it can be accessed
on a modern equipment if it's malware
we're looking at we're probably more
interested in what the code's doing
because we're interested in how it's
doing that and things if we're reverse
engineering the bios we're probably
actually interested in both because we
want to be able to sort of produce an
equivalent and if we know how it's
structured because that's what other
things are using we know how it's
implemented we can work out the ideas we
can then go off and give it to someone
else who can write a new version never
having looked at the original
and so on or we can write a report on
how the malware works so we can then go
and sort of look for certain things on
our network we might see as we reverse
engineer the malware
for example that it's going to send data
to some ip address or something we can
then set the network up to detect that
and then say hang on that machine's
infected possibly then go and
investigate
so reverse engineering is going from
something very very specific the binary
and getting it
to
a more general thing so we've got more
of an idea of what's going on you will
use some of the same techniques you
would if you've ever read a program you
sometimes you get given a program the
source code you're playing when you just
open it up and read it because you want
to extend it you want to add some
features to it or you're just wanting to
understand how it works you're already
doing some of the things that you would
do when you reverse engineering it's
differences when you're here things are
very very specific some of the things
that you've got here like if you write a
program c you'd probably be able to see
what the data structures will look like
because they will have a struct and
you'll see them laid out you will see an
array uh if you're running something in
java you'll see the objects define the
classes that define those objects and so
on when we've got a binary when we've
got an executable
you can't read it
at the human level if i um well let's
just have a look at a binary if i just
cat
a binary here wc
then what we end up with there is some
text in it we can see it's got the apple
certification
but the vast majority of it
is well
unreadable we can make things slightly
easier for ourselves
and we can run it through a hex dump and
just have a look at the heck the actual
bytes their values as hexadecimal values
so we do the same thing and i'll
put it on screen we can now start to see
what the program looks like we can see
some of the
magic hexadecimal numbers that apple
used to identify this
as a executable file and what you could
do is find out if you looked at the
format of this and again we'll do a
video on executable formats at some
point
because i think it'll be a good one you
can find out within the file probably
around here
where the program starts
and you could and i have done this on a
couple of occasions work this out
manually you could look at the
hexadecimal bytes and say that five five
that's what we call the op code the code
that represents an operation that's this
that has this effect
four eight has some other effect and so
on and we'll work out what the prone
does
that's the manual way to do it
the alternative is that we can use a
tool called a disassembler and there's
various ones around the one that is most
commonly used is probably ida the
interactive disassembler which i've got
open here and when you open up the
program in ida it converts it
into the op codes
that make up that program so for example
rather than seeing
a series of numbers i see that this is
pushing
rbp onto the stacks the machine code
instruction push takes the value in a
register or some other
location and pushes it onto the stack
for you and so you can start to read
what the program's doing
and then you can effectively do the same
sort of thing that you do if you're
reading a program to sort of work out
what's going on
but as i said
this is the level that you're dealing
with there's no thing saying this is a
data structure
you may see the program storing data in
a memory location or reading data from a
memory location
it's up to you to piece together what
these instructions are doing
to understand
what the program's doing now you can do
get the software to help you so for
example
ida has a view where it'll sort of break
the program up based on where this sort
of loops and what you don't have loops
in machine code what you have are
branches or jumps which you can use to
create
loops by saying if this condition is met
then jump otherwise don't jump don't
branch
and so what ida tries to do is to sort
of break up the program into these
blocks and sort of show you with lines
between them
what's happening at different point that
makes it easy to see things but it's
still exactly the same code not all
disassemblers do that it's a nice
feature for looking at what's happening
so what you end up doing when you
reverse engineering is a bit like being
a detective
you've got to follow what's going on the
program code as you read it will give
you information about what's going on
and you can infer from that certain
things and so you can look at things and
say
okay that's likely to be
an array or that's likely to be forming
a linked list and from that you can
start to infer what the data structures
are you'll probably get it wrong so
you'll need to keep notes and then
you'll some come back and say okay no
it's not that type because of this
therefore i can work out what's going on
here so what i've got loaded up at the
moment
is the word count program just to see
how you can start to unpick what's going
on
in this program this program i've never
opened up in ida before now
one of the things that makes it easier
as a job
is that it's unusual for the code to
exist in isolation if it wants to do
something
it's got to talk to
other bits of the system this program if
it's going to run needs to talk to the
operating system
if it's talking to the operating system
it's going to have to call system calls
which are defined so if you look on
microsoft website you can see the
windows systems walls if you look at the
documentation on apple's website you can
see the ones they use same for linux for
example here
i can see that this program here is
using the call instruction
and it's calling
the get opt library function which is
used to find
options that are in the program so just
by opening it up and spotting get up
there
i can see that it's also passed a string
to get opt and if i look at the
documentation
for get opt command 3 get opt
then we can see that it takes in three
values the first one is the number of
arguments
the second one is the array with those
arguments in the sort of standard rc rb
that you get
in a c program and then the last one
is the option string and that option
string is defined here
as containing the following elements
individual characters and characters
followed by a colon to indicate an
option argument is to follow
so we can look through that string and
we can spot that string here and so
immediately just opening this up
with a disassembler
i now know that this program can take
the option c
l
m or w and i can see that it's setting
rdx one of the registers to have a
pointer to that string
therefore because i know how functions
are called on the x8664 architecture
that i'm looking at here i know that
that's going to be the ops string
argument i can say that okay this
program has
four possible arguments c l m or w
okay well what do they do well we can
continue reading through the program
and see what they do in the program and
we can also see
how the program works
at this point so that's just a quick
example we're not going to go through
the whole program to work out how it
counts the words although we could leave
that as an exercise to the viewer you
can download a free version of ida pro
or other disassemblers is binary ninja
there's a command-line one called redare
there's ghidra which is available from
the nsa and things that you can play you
can work at
look at these things so something like
the word counting program is relatively
simple and we could have gone further
and looked at how it actually sort of
counted the words we could have seen by
looking through that codes
sort of what does it define a word as
what characters would it take of
defining or what series of characters
would it have taken as defining a word
what series of characters would they
have taken as defining the the gaps
between the word the spaces and so on
and we could then produce a
specification for how that program
worked
we can do exactly the same thing with
any other piece of software whether it's
the bios chip
on a pc whether it's the doomsday
software we can understand how the data
structured on that whether it's a piece
of malware we can use the same ideas
looking at the code looking at how it
manipulates data and sort of use that to
sort of infer from that evidence of how
the sort of data is structured and then
we can test that we can come up with
in and what do i mean by testing that
well we can say well
if this is say we think if this is a
linked list say we think we see some
code that says this might be a linked
list or we can say well okay
is it checking for null at the end of
the linked list which is what you'll
often do can we see the code doing that
um if it isn't
maybe it's a ring buffer and it's doing
something like that we can start to ask
questions based on the
deductions we make
whether something is true whether the
deduction stands up and as we look at
more code
that will become more obvious or it'll
contradict
that deduction and we can start to sort
of piece what's going on
in the program
as i said you can do this with something
like
the bios with the doomsday discs with
the word counting program or with a
piece of malware and again there you do
exactly the same thing to find out what
is this malware doing what part of the
system is it trying to infect how does
it try and hide itself on the system
does it even try and hide itself or is
it just completely destructive um is it
trying to talk to any other systems on
the network it's not the only tool you
have for something like malware but it
can really help you to see what's going
on and you might find things that you
wouldn't spot in other ways
new feature new feature probably is
right sean is currently reverse
engineering his camera to find out how
he's worked because he hasn't back home
because he hasn't read the manual but uh
i haven't read the manual uh it's
classic it's got about four pages and
then it's look at the pdf yeah yeah
that's the standard